[Music]
good afternoon thank you so much for
coming to the second annual chemists at
Yale lightning talks I'm very excited to
have a bunch of great presenters today
and I just want to thank everyone who
helped out with the setup today who
helped getting everybody ready and this
was a labor of love and thank you so
much to everyone who helped make this
happen here today I want to jump right
in and get get started on everything so
the first thing here we have Yulia who
is going to be our first presenter and
Yulia is a senior lecturer in the Slovak
Department and is a canvas quiz guru
aside from teaching julia has published
articles in a lot of gnash in national
peer-reviewed journals and is also
interested in working with technology
digital humanities and heritage language
learning and today she's going to be
talking about how she integrated the
canvas quizzes into her course thank you
so much thank you all for coming
I've great to see so many familiar faces
and some of you teach language too so I
hope that you would find this
presentation helpful
because as I was saying tymberlee
language teaches invariably
do a lot of grading and in my mind I
will tell you a little bit about the
structure of this course and why I find
canvas so so helpful so I teach in OVC
our introductory Russian firstly Russian
as many introductory language courses at
Yale it has multiple sections so I'm the
course coordinator I oversee multiple
sections and I get every year new
teaching assistants who have never
taught before so obviously one of the
Paramount tasks is to ensure that
gradient is consistent across multiple
sections and as anybody who has been in
the similar situation knows it is very
difficult for a an experienced teacher
to teach a new teacher to grade exactly
like yourself because it's not just
finding the correct answer that you can
teach them to do you will give the key
that's not a problem but to make sure
how
certain components of the test are
evaluated as a whole is it worth one
point
is it worth half a point is it
considered a spelling error is that
considered repeated error in which case
you would not and so forth and again the
other challenge that we have in
introductory language classes we want to
give these quizzes and exams fairly
often we cannot teach a class where
we'll just give a midterm and the final
that would have disastrous results I
know that majority of my colleagues and
as do we in Russia we have bi-weekly
unit tests that means their grades get a
letter or in canvas case its percentage
grade and we on the weeks that are off
weeks from the test we have what we call
low stakes quizzes that is to say this
would also be a quiz but it'll be
shorter and instead of a letter grade
you will have a percentage why do we do
that we feel that in introductory level
it's very important to have this what we
call level checks or progress
measurements because if student gets a
very low score on this interim low stake
quiz well it tells them okay well the
material on this unit really needs more
work so by the time they approach unit
tests they over already had that
feedback and again I know that this is
something that again I see surely in
Hebrew and Angele in Korean we all have
this approach it's very important to
give the student frequent feedback at
the same time so in paper testing it
also in addition to obvious changes for
uniformity of grading as I said there
was another challenge of simply if you
correct mistake by hand the student may
or may not be able to decipher what you
wrote it's a huge problem in the larger
assignment say because each test
invariably has a free writing portion
and I'll show you in a minute
you know whether they are able to read
your corrections god only knows what do
they read it you don't know either
so in canvas it's taken care of
beautifully because you can type your
feedback and student will immediately
see it you will also set up the test and
I will show you where the correct
answers are immediately shown and
reviews
feature typically we use this feature
because at the air fortunately we don't
have a problem with academic dishonesty
so once you hit submit you will
immediately see just like you do now on
SATs or GRE you will have your own score
so bio score I mean of course then I
will invariably go into the exam and
make sure that machine has subtracted
the points correctly and there is also a
free writing portion of each test which
the canvas now can currently cannot
grade but I will grade by hand and I
will leave comments so again for us
using canvas in first-year Russian has
proven to be of tremendous benefit both
on the learners progress because then it
assures transparencies did you see
exactly what went wrong on consistency
of gradient then there are no more
debates oh you've taken for this you
didn't take for that and so forth across
the sections and of course the frequent
feedback finally there is a great
organizational benefit because we've all
been in a situation when student is sick
or they have to go out of town in other
words they have a legitimate excuse that
they cannot take the test with a group
and then you have to somehow make
arrangements so that they have to come
in during the office hours and again
even on organization level it's very
difficult because you have to find
mutually convenient time to Proctor
again canvas takes care of it
wonderfully because you as a teacher if
you know that the reason is legitimate
you can open the test on demand which
sometimes we do and it works beautifully
what else we do presume this student did
very poorly on exam and it's up to the
teacher to decide whether how you want
to approach presume somebody I don't
know got very stressed or they had some
sort of issue and they got very low low
score then you can go into the test and
allow second attempt and it will be
measured so now I will demonstrate for
you I mean I put on the abstract that I
will show you my full semester but that
doesn't really matter because I'm
looking with this now so this is my
second semester of this again I've used
it last year too so it's a second year
or the fourth semester of this so how
that works so
so the child the children are not
confused so each chapter is organized
into this modules so you can see in the
June January we started with unit 7
there is a vocabulary quiz because I
said when they do write and then there
is a chapter test which is variably lost
so what do I do with a unit test loss
take quizzes all quizzes I was only 10
percent of total grade so again it's at
low stake testing which research has
shown has tremendous benefits because
you want to test without like students
being too stressed about it so I will
preview so you see what the test looks
like I don't know if I can go and show
in the privacy interest of the quiz
statistics so it looks like this ok you
can set it up it's just a simple
vocabulary quiz everybody does it
it's very standard so from English into
Russian then you have some components
which will go well this one is only it's
only from English into Russian but
usually typically I set up two ways if
it's vocabulary quiz it will be from
into the target language and then from
target language back into English now
you can of course change it at any time
so what is super super nice about this
if you want to see how people did in a
particular section or across the board
if your quiz was set up well you go into
this and it will show you overall
performance so if cpg people did pretty
good I don't know if it shows me the
average score 90 percent very nice so it
obviously it was set up well I'll show
you one more thing because I get the
card for questions I'll show you the
test okay you want to see the test a
little bit just one because I do say it
wants to see same thing
so test compose that again I'll just
just one so Gregan is beautiful so
listen of course nobody has any problems
was listening so green you don't worry
about the green okay so red of course
you have to see how the canvas how can
the scores it so here there was nothing
for me to do because obviously I mean I
went in and that was issues there were
various issues here it's not the best
test to show of course but in any case
you only look so the green one you don't
even have to worry it's tremendous time
saver because green you just scroll a
red one you should see like here you see
I avoided here two and a half points
because I gave you back half the credit
who here because I treat it as a
spelling error so on the red one you
look and then you go again this is a
very poor example to show because
obvious is a very bad work but this is a
free writing and then so look so this is
a free writing for the free writing
prompt right students rights then I can
when I give you I say look this word
this is only worth 14 out of possible 20
points then I tell you here why it is
because I have this comment you see
where I correct your issues here for
over overall comment I didn't say
anything but it allows you to put the
comments in like see this this work was
turned in late you see that so it's very
nice if you have multiple attempts it
will show you well this is obviously a
very good work 99.5
and so forth and so forth but it's
wonderful because then again they can
see immediately the problems what they
need to work on and improve and again I
can go back to quiz statistics and I
will see how the sections how the
sections did it yeah questions
[Music]
yes excellent question so unit test the
one that you're looking at now we'll be
taking in class because there is also a
listening component that I will play
like if they don't have listened before
let's see they will be playing class so
anything that I get letter grade and is
a weighted heavier because you need test
count for 40% of the grade of overall
grade so yes I will do that in class but
capillary quizzes which you which was
the first item demonstrated vocabulary
quizzes are considered low stake item
and those would be done out of course
out of class time but that's a good
point because what I intend to do later
I mean later wait maybe next academic
year I want to add more of these low
stake quizzes so rather than giving like
white a week maybe I'll give a couple of
week because it's always good you can
cheat you can make them learn vocabulary
you know you've seen that problem
who set up your canvass presence did you
do it yourself did you hire an expert
well I am a great I had great help
whiskey's from Christine Constantina
and so we work together she was generous
very generous with your time and again
both Kimberly and Christine have really
helped tremendously and now every time I
have a problem because I still do I ask
Christine and she helps me but I mean
again the more you use it the better it
gets the first time I thought it was
horrible because you know every answer
is a new screen you realize it but I
mean sure you get a hang of it and again
I mean Toby truth be told it yes it is
time-consuming to set up but it's
absolutely well worth it because like
last year we spent tremendous amount of
time setting it up but now it's all
there so now I can concentrate on
modifying and adding because also I'm
sure somebody will talk about it
canvas has this beautiful button copy
resources of which I can happily talk
next time because resources too are much
easier to maintain and copy from
semester to semester it's really I mean
I'm a huge fan of this program
absolutely questions you can I mean for
my particular situation it's not
practical but yes absolutely when you
says I set up the quiz you can
absolutely do you can have bank of
questions and it will pick from the bank
again for us because the first year or
introductory languages are so sequential
I can do it in my other class for
example I can advanced or whatever in
heritage but in the introductory
language level this the points that you
wish to test are so few and so
particular that you don't want to so the
answer is yes the system allows that but
we don't do it for this particular
course great thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]